[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHIDEH SHAHIDI:
Welcome to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Shideh.
And today I will be talking
about AI inference with GCP
on Intel.
You can ask questions anytime.
And we have folks from
Intel and Googlers
who'll be taking your questions.
Let's get started.
We will be talking about value
proposition of Intel Xeon
and GCP, and how to configure
your GCP environment with Intel
hardware and software
optimizations,
and tools to get the best
performance for your AI
application.
We will present to
you some of the work
that we have been doing with
Google over the course of two
years and how we can
bring these optimizations
and tools available
and easy to use in GCP.
So here's an agenda of the talk.
First, we will go over a
brief overview of Intel
in AI, our strategy
and strengths.
We will continue with
talking about our Xeon CPUs
available in GCP.
Then we talk about how we get
the best performance for AI
applications, tuning and
optimizing different frameworks
to run best on our hardware.
And lastly, we talk about our
two-plus years of collaboration
with Google Cloud to make
this performance easily
available to GCP developers.
I'd like to start with a real
example of an AI customer,
to highlight the value
that Intel brings to AI.
This is showing the lifecycle of
an industrial defect-detection
project.
And we are showing the
breakdown of this lifecycle
into different phases.
While other projects will be
different in time breakdown,
the steps are
typically the same.
At the bottom, overall
time to solution
is the complete AI
journey, including
steps from opportunity
assessment to development
and deployment, and ultimately,
evaluation of the end result.
In the middle, we zoom in on
the develop and deploy portion
of the overall solution,
which includes sourcing data
proof of concept development
inference deployment,
as well as integration
into a broader application.
At the top, we zoom in
further on the proof
of concept development
itself, where
you can see that
data preparation took
a majority of the
development time,
followed by training
the model and testing,
plus documentation.
As you can see,
there is a lot that
needs to happen before and
after the compute intensive part
of the lifecycle, which we refer
to as the core machine learning
and deep learning phase.
Intel works with customers
across the entire lifecycle
to speed up overall
time to solution.
It's important to think about
the overall flow of your data,
including the data management
and other headaches,
and what would get you to do
the deployment faster rather
than accelerating one portion
of your solution at a premium.
Now, in order to expand on
this concept a little more,
let's take a quick look
at the multiple approaches
to get your data ready before
your deployment and development
cycles.
A key factor in
deciding your approach
is where you land on
the data spectrum.
Is your data coming
from one source or many?
Is it structured
or unstructured?
How much volume are
you dealing with?
Is it mission critical or not?
Is it streaming live or batch?
Who needs access to it?
These are some of the
questions that you
should be asking before
you start your process
of the deep learning journey.
Are there any
regulatory requirements?
Depending on your answers
to these questions,
we would recommend different
approaches and different tools
to integrate, store, process,
manage, and analyze your data.
For example, if you're dealing
with live streaming data that's
coming from multiple
sensors, you
would want to consider tools
for unified high throughput
and low latency real
time data ingestion.
The bottom line is there are
many different approaches
to set up your data and get
your data ready for your AI
development and deployment.
And Intel works with a
vast ecosystem in this area
to optimize their
solution to run
best on our latest hardware.
Leveraging these
optimizations will
provide the best performance
for the data prep cycle,
as well as little to no overhead
and headache for managing
and moving your data.
Now that we talked
about different cycles
before we get to the
core machine learning,
deep learning of
your AI application,
let's take a quick look at
Intel's complete portfolio
of software and
solutions facts that
run on Intel's diverse
portfolio of hardware products.
With our software stack,
we target every level
of AI expertise and engagement,
from library developers,
to data scientists,
to app developers.
We also have a rich
catalog of solutions
based on internal
and public use cases
to share with
solution architects
across different segments.
To simplify the
things a bit, I'd
like to focus on a
handful of these tools
today that most apply
to GCP developers.
Let's start with
Intel Xeon processor,
which is the foundation
of our AI solutions,
especially in GCP.
We will be talking about
some of the improvements
in the latest
generation of Xeon CPU
and how that would translate to
better performance for your AI
application.
Next is MKL-DNN, our
open-source deep neural network
functions for our CPU.
Library developers can use
these primitives to accelerate
performance on our hardware.
Then we focus on the next
layer of stack with Intel
optimized frameworks,
especially TensorFlow,
for the purpose of
this presentation,
as well as Intel
distribution of Python.
And lastly, we will focus on
our deep learning development
toolkit, OpenVino, which makes
it possible to run inference
with optimized performance
on a wide variety of hardware
backgrounds using a unified API.
Intel has been
partnering with Google
for many years on their
data center infrastructure.
And since 2016, we have
been collaborating closely
with GCP on cloud solutions
that run on our hardware.
To summarize the strategy
for our engagements on AI,
there are three pillars
that we focus on.
First is the product.
Through our very close
collaboration with Google,
GCP was the first
cloud service provider
to provide access to our
latest generation Xeon scalable
processor in their cloud
environment, even months
before general market
availability of our product.
Google is always at the
leading edge of the technology.
And we continue to
collaborate to provide time
to market for our products
for GCP developers.
The second pillar
of our strategy
is working on
tools and libraries
to enable maximum performance
from our hardware.
This work, as I
explained earlier,
spans across multiple
layers of software
from primitives and libraries
to unified compilers and SDKs,
and optimized deep learning and
machine learning frameworks.
And lastly, we
collaborate with GCP
to make these tools available
and easy to access in the GCP
environment for the developers.
So let's talk a little
bit about our products.
Intel Xeon scalable product,
also known as Skylake,
is the latest generation of
Intel CPUs available in GCP
since first quarter of 2017.
These processors increase
the number of CPU cores
from previous generation, which
translates to 50% larger VMs.
You can now select
Skylake-based VMs
with up to 96 vCPUs and memory
as large as 1.4 terabyte.
Skylake also incorporates
many micro-architectural
advancements, including
significantly larger caches,
which translates to applications
being able to store larger data
structures closer to the core.
If your data structure
doesn't fit on the core,
you have more memory bandwidth
to access the memory faster.
And on the execution
side, Skylake
decreases the instruction
latencies of many instructions
and adds wider execution.
At the same time, Skylake
implements the latest
generation of Intel vector
instructions, AVX-512,
which provides twice as wide as
previous generation in vector
sizes and can boost floating
point performance up to 82%.
All of this translates to
faster vCPUs and containers
based on Skylake in GCE and GKE,
as well as other GCP products.
As you know, one
of the essentials
behind convolutional
neural network modeling
is matrix multiplication.
In Xeon CPUs, we're
accelerating instructions
to perform these operations
as efficiently as possible.
Skylake today
supports FP32 vector
multiply and add instructions,
as well as INT8 instructions.
Next generation of
Intel Xeon processors
offers our new
VNNI instructions.
VNNI stands for vector
neural network instructions.
And includes
hardware acceleration
for INT8 convolution
instructions.
In next generation of
Intel Xeon processors,
3-AVX instructions to
perform intake operations
are fused into one, providing
speedup due to consuming
less clock cycles.
We're working very closely
with framework developers
to make these
instructions integrated
into their frameworks so
that they can take advantage
of the performance boost
that these instructions bring
to your application.
So we talked about
our new instructions
and all the goodness
in the hardware
that our new products
bring to GCP.
However, any hardware is
only as good as the software
that runs on top of it.
So in addition to providing
the features in our hardware,
we have been heavily focused
on software optimizations
to leverage all the
features in our hardware.
We have been engaged very
closely over the last few years
with different
framework developers
to integrate our libraries and
upstream our optimizations.
Here's an example
of our optimization
work over the course
of one year and a half.
From July 2017, which is when we
launched Skylake CPUs publicly,
there has been about 5.4x
improvement in inference
performance, solely from
software optimizations.
This is a comparison on
the same Intel hardware
and can speak to the power
of our optimizations.
From now till next year, when
our next generation Xeon CPUs
will be available
publicly, we're
expecting inference
performance to roughly double,
due to the new
hardware acceleration
instructions, implementation,
and the additional performance
optimizations.
This chart is based on
ResNet 50 performance.
Obviously for a less
compute-bound workload,
where there are other
bottlenecks in the hardware,
the results will be less
pronounced but still
very significant.
Now, let's focus on
TensorFlow for a bit
and talk briefly about the
framework optimizations.
We spoke earlier about our
optimized deep neural network
libraries.
MKL-DNN, as I mentioned, is our
open source Math Kernel Library
for deep neural networks
and the main building block
of our framework optimizations.
MKL-DNN is highly optimized
using sometimes very low level,
as low as assembly code.
And the API has been developed
with feedback and interactions
with major framework owners.
The optimizations are
done at multiple layers.
First, all the primitives,
such as convolution,
matrix multiplication,
and batch normalization
are rewritten to take advantage
of the latest wide vector
instructions.
Next, the different
layers are parallelized
to allow for efficient use
of all the available cores
in the hardware.
And lastly, balanced
use of pre-fetching,
cache blocking techniques,
and data formats
that promote spatial
and temporal locality
are used to make data more
available when the execution
units need it.
In addition to using
MKL-DNN primitives,
we use other techniques to
integrate into TensorFlow.
There are things that we do
like layout optimization,
replacing default TensorFlow
operations, fuse operations,
propagating intermediate states.
And we have our custom
CPU pool allocator,
which basically helps with
avoiding costly page misses
and page clears.
We have been working with
Google on these optimizations
for two-plus years and
continue to collaborate
to realize the gains from the
new instructions and framework
performance.
Now, in addition to TensorFlow
and other deep learning
frameworks, we have
been contributing
our optimized
libraries to Python.
We have accelerated NumPy,
SciPy, and SciKit-Learn
with Intel MKL.
Our optimizations are available
through conda and Anaconda
Cloud for general public
use and are upstreamed back
to main Python trunk.
If you're interested
to find out more
on Intel distribution of
Python and some performance
proof [INAUDIBLE],, we
have a good write-up
on this on our Intel
website software.
I think there's a link on the
slide that you can refer to.
And here is just an example of
using the scikit-learn library
in GCP environment to achieve
significant performance
speedup.
This is using a K-Means
clustering algorithm.
You can see gains
of up to 23x faster
for using the Intel scikit-learn
versus a stock scikit-learn
library from Python.
And this is run on GCP on
a 96 vCPU Skylake instance.
Now that we talked about some
of the Intel optimized libraries
and frameworks, I'd
like to spend some time
to tell you a little bit about
our collaboration with Google
Cloud to bring the performance
of these optimizations
to you as an easily
accessible asset in GCP.
We have created Docker images
with both Intel optimized
TensorFlow and Intel
distribution of Python
on Docker Hub and GitHub.
There's a link to
access these Dockers.
Basically, these will bring all
the goodness of our software
as a one-click Docker
download for your image
so you can use these to develop
faster and more efficiently.
We've also been
working with Google
to make Intel
distribution of Python,
as well as some Intel
performance libraries,
available on Google
Container Registry.
The Intel performance
libraries include libraries
like Intel Math Kernel library,
Intel Threading Building
Blocks, Intel NPI, IPP, and data
analytics acceleration library.
For you to be able to use
these libraries on your VMs,
you need to make sure that
your runtime is actually
available for these libraries.
And there is good
instructions on the link
on the website where you
can download the runtimes
and make them available
in your VM instances.
In addition to containers with
Intel optimized libraries,
we have been
collaborating with Google
to create Optimized
Virtual Machine images.
In addition to ease
of use and deployment,
these images guarantee that
the developers are always
leveraging the latest
version of the optimizations
through these images.
Recently, GCP released two
Intel optimized VM images,
one with TensorFlow,
1.12.0, using
the latest MKL-DNN
and MKL libraries,
and another one with
Intel optimizations
for three Python libraries--
numPy SciPy, and scikit-learn.
These images automate setting
up the environment variables
with the right variables and are
available through Google Cloud
Marketplace, GCE, OS images,
and command line interface.
I would like to spend
a little bit of time
to walk you through
how to get started
with selecting the
right platform in GCP
and accessing the
optimized images.
To start off in Google
Compute Engine, when you're
creating an instance, go to
the CPU platform pull-down menu
and select Intel
Skylake or later
to guarantee that
your application will
leverage the latest
hardware enhancements.
We talked earlier about
the advantages of Skylake
over a previous generation CPU.
And I'm glad to mention that
in terms of availability,
Skylake is now available in
16 out of 17 GCP regions.
If you're not using
the console, you
can use the min-cpu-platform
flag in Cloud Shell
to select your CPU.
In any of the 16 zones
with Skylake availability,
you can set the flag
to Intel Skylake
when you create your VM to
guarantee running on Skylake.
As we discussed earlier, the
main premise of the VM images
is to make Intel
optimizations and tools easily
available to GCP developers.
One of the ways for accessing
the VM images with Intel
optimized TensorFlow
or Intel optimized
Python is to use Google
Cloud Marketplace.
In your Google Cloud
console environment,
click on Marketplace and look
for deep learning VM images.
With one click, you
will be able to deploy
these images on your VM.
You can also access
these images on GCE.
If you're looking for more
control when you're setting up
your VM, deploy these
optimized OS images
by changing the boot
disk and selecting one
of the Intel optimized images.
To take full advantage
of the optimizations
on the latest
architecture, make sure
that you select your CPU
platform as Intel Skylake
or later while doing this.
And if you're using Google
call command line interface,
you can launch the VM images
using the following command
line options.
Set the image family variable to
one of the Intel-specific image
types at the time you are
creating your instance.
You can also set the
min-cpu-platform variable
to the latest
Intel CPU, Skylake.
Now I'd like to talk to
you about our toolkit.
So we talked about
the libraries.
We talked about different
layers of software stack.
And we focused on the libraries
and frameworks so far.
And I'd like to talk to you a
little bit about our toolkit
and what helps you develop
for Intel hardware.
So our latest project
with Google Cloud
has been on Kubeflow pipeline.
And we've been
working on integrating
part of our development toolkit
into the Kubeflow pipeline.
Earlier we talked a little
bit about our software toolkit
with a common API across
different Intel hardware.
This software toolkit
is known as OpenVino,
which stands for
open visual inference
and neural net optimization.
OpenVino has three
main components.
First is a deep learning
deployment kit, or DLDT.
The second one is
an OpenCV and Media
SDK used for traditional
vision and video processing.
And third is a collection
of pre-trained models
and tutorials.
In summary, OpenVino provides
a unified programming model
across hardware, is optimized
for performance and memory
footprint, is extensible
for custom workloads,
provides broad operating
system support,
is self-contained for a simple
out-of-the-box experience,
and is open-source for the
community to contribute
and enhance.
The components that
we will focus on today
are basically the DLDT, which
offers a model optimizer
and an inference engine
with unified APIs
across different Intel hardware.
So Intel and Google
are partnering
to bring the performance
and ease of use of DLDT
to GCP developers by adding
DLDT containers to the Kubeflow
pipeline.
Suppose you're a data scientist,
creating an end-to-end solution
based on some medical images.
Your work can be done through
multiple different containers.
The data ingestion,
data transformation,
and data validation containers
facilitate reading the data,
transforming the data
to the expected format,
and validating the data as
usable and properly labeled.
This data is passed to
the trainer container.
The output is a
trained model that
is passed to the model
validation container
to ensure the model is ready
for deployment or serving.
The trained model is then used
for serving by your end party.
The way OpenVino is
integrated into this flow
is that the trained model is
fed to the DLDT model optimizer.
The model optimizer
generates optimized IR.
And then the optimized IR
is fed into the serving
with DLDT container basically
using the inference engine
to run this as efficiently as
possible on the Intel hardware
backend.
So here we have some examples of
integrating Kubeflow pipelines
with OpenVino containers.
In the links provided here,
we have the two examples.
And we invite you to go
ahead and try these examples,
and just go through the flow
of integrating these containers
into the Kubeflow pipeline.
You can learn more about
OpenVino and its benefits
using the link at the bottom.
Also, my colleagues
are going to deliver
a webinar on Introduction to
AI Pipelines and Intel OpenVino
Integration that
I highly encourage
you to watch to learn.
So just to wrap up,
here are some resources
for more information on Intel
resources for AI developers.
Intel AI Academy
is the best place
to start to learn more about
Intel's assets and tools.
AI Builders Solution Library
is a great one-stop shop
to find Intel AI
technology based solutions
for different verticals.
And Intel's landing page on
GCP is a great starting point
to learn more about Intel
technologies enabled in GCP.
With that, I would
like to thank you again
for the opportunity of
introducing some of our AI
technologies in GCP.
Please stay tuned for our
live Q&A. My colleague,
Banu, will join to help
answer some questions.
We will be back in
less than a minute.
SHIDEH SHAHIDI: So I
have Banu here with me.
And we're going to try to
answer as many questions
from the audience as we can.
We've collected some
questions while I was talking.
Banu, so here's a
question asking,
"What are some of the
examples of customers
using Xeon for AI?"
BANU NAGASUNDARAM: That's
a really good question.
So for AI, we have
a lot of customers
who use our Xeon processors
for both machine learning
and deep learning workloads.
Specifically in deep
learning for AI,
we have two different
types of workloads
for inference and for
training that we support.
Our customers use Xeon scalable
processors, our SkyLake CPUs,
for streaming inference
and batch inference.
One example for streaming
inference that we recently
talked about was Taboola.
It is a recommendation
engine that does web-serving
for web-serving applications.
And they use our Xeon CPUs
for bringing the data in
to stream it in and then
do real-time inference
on the data.
And they offer around 360
billion recommendations
for a billion unique
users every month.
So that is one example
of streaming inference.
And then for batch
inference, we have
customers like GE
Healthcare that
uses Xeon CPUs specificly for
image recognition workloads.
And their workload is on drug--
more like CT scan and
pharmaceutical related.
And they use the Xeon
CPUs for batch inference,
which is when they have a
database, a collected set
of data.
And they use that to run
inference in large batch sizes.
And they have realized
tremendous amount
of performance improvements
by going to the Xeon CPUs.
And then we also have
training workloads.
We have companies like Novartis
in the pharmaceutical industry
doing high content screening,
which is basically looking
at really large image sizes.
If you look at some
of the benchmarks
that we use, for
example, like ResNet-50,
they use an ImageNet database.
And that is a smaller
set of images.
But in real life, our customers
use much larger image sizes.
And Novartis is one of the
examples on training, where
they have achieved
improvements in the time
to train and throughput
using the Xeon CPUs.
So those are some of the
examples of our customers using
the Xeon for AI.
SHIDEH SHAHIDI: I think the
next question kind of alludes
to that as well.
The next question is, "Can we
also run training on Xeon?"
So we've been talking
about inference,
and how to set it up, and how
to use it on Xeon and GCP.
Do we have any examples of
customers running training
on Xeon?
Is it is it doable?
BANU NAGASUNDARAM: Right.
Yeah.
That's a good question.
So Xeon CPUs are
multi-purpose CPUs,
which are used for a wide
variety of workloads.
And deep learning
is a subset of one
of those workloads that
is very important to Intel
and our customers.
As part of that, you can run
training on the Xeon CPUs.
One of the examples I
alluded to was Novartis.
But there are a few others
that I can touch upon.
For example, in the
convergence of HPC and AI,
we have workloads that
run for our customers
on tremendously large databases.
One of the examples is--
recently we talked about, in the
Supercomputing 2018 conference,
on how [INAUDIBLE],, a
French research institute,
used Xeon CPUs to scale training
across multiple CPUs, almost
128 nodes, achieving a higher
level of scaling efficiency
and getting to the
accuracy that is needed.
So that is one of
the examples of how
you can run training on Xeons.
Do you want to add?
SHIDEH SHAHIDI: Yeah.
Actually, as a matter
of fact, in GCP,
we've had a few customers that
are doing training on Xeon.
Their applications go
across from visual effects
to satellite imagery.
The Cart Lab is one of
them who has publicly
announced that they're
doing training on Xeon.
And there are a couple others
that are actually doing
this in a GCP environment.
BANU NAGASUNDARAM: OK.
Yeah.
One other example that came
to my mind was also CERN.
They use the Large
Hadron Collider.
And they have a massive amount
of data set that they collect.
And they run high performance
computing, like Monte Carlo
simulations, to do that.
And they use Xeon CPUs to
do distributed training
across those 256 nodes.
And we showed in one
example on 3D-GAN,
which is generated adversarial
networks, and showing
scaling efficiency across
multiple Xeon nodes as well.
SHIDEH SHAHIDI: Got it.
OK.
Great.
So let's see.
BANU NAGASUNDARAM: I can
ask you the next one.
So "when can we get access
to deep learning boost
on our VNNI on GCP?"
SHIDEH SHAHIDI: OK,
so that's a good one.
So deep learning boost
and VNNI instructions
are available in our next
generation Intel Xeon CPUs.
We're actually shipping
samples to our customers
towards the end of this year.
When it's going to be
available in GCP is really
a question for GCP reps.
So I really encourage you to
be in touch with your GCP reps
in order to find out
their timelines on when
they're going to make this
available in their platform.
So I have one for you now.
Actually, let's
go to the last one
first because I want
you to answer that one.
And then if you have time, we'll
come back to the previous one.
So "what different
topologies and frameworks
are optimized for
Intel hardware?"
BANU NAGASUNDARAM:
That's a good one.
So you did touch upon
the Intel portfolio slide
and showed the
different frameworks
that we optimized for.
So to summarize, we do
TensorFlow primarily
for framework optimizations.
But in addition to
that, we also do MXnet.
Caffe, too.
And then PyTorch
and PaddlePaddle
are some of the examples
of the frameworks
that we optimize for.
In terms of topologies, we do
a wide variety of topologies.
And they are very
related to the use cases
that our customers
are applying for.
For example, we run
image recognition,
which was like the Resnet-50,
Inception v3 examples.
We do object detection, which
YOLO is an example of that.
We do image
segmentation, where we
are looking at specific
segments of an image,
and that's like Mask R-CNN.
We also do language translation,
which is the neural machine
translation workloads.
And then some of the other
ones that come to mind
are text-to-speech.
WaveNet is a good example
of text-to-speech workload,
and even recommender
systems, for example,
like Wide & Deep or neural
collaborative filtering.
So it's basically a
huge range of topologies
that we optimize for on
these different frameworks.
SHIDEH SHAHIDI: OK, so not only
libraries and primitives, we
also have frameworks.
And that's the part that we also
work with different topologies
in the different workloads.
And I think probably we have
time for one more question.
"What is the benefit of
Intel optimized software,
and why do I need it?"
BANU NAGASUNDARAM:
That's a good question.
[LAUGHTER]
I can start, and then
you can add to it.
SHIDEH SHAHIDI: Sure.
BANU NAGASUNDARAM:
So what Shideh
has have been talking about
to you today has been about--
what are the different
things we can do?
But why do we need to do it?
For example, the hardware
that we build, like Skylake,
has an ADX-512 instructions.
And our next generation
Xeon CPU will
have the VNNI instructions.
In order to get the performance
out of these instructions,
you need the libraries that
are developed on top of it
to use these instructions.
And then once you have
those libraries developed,
you need the framework
to call these libraries.
So that is why we say
that you need the latest
optimized software
on Intel hardware
in order to get the
best performance.
Do you want to give a GCP--
SHIDEH SHAHIDI: It's pretty
much the same thing in GCP.
BANU NAGASUNDARAM: OK.
OK.
SHIDEH SHAHIDI: As long
as you have the frameworks
and topologies available, make
sure that you're using them.
Make sure you're
using the latest
and greatest of the
hardware and the software.
Give it a try.
And your performance
is going to see
the advantage and the boost.
BANU NAGASUNDARAM: Right.
SHIDEH SHAHIDI: So I think with
that, we're going to close.
Stay tuned for the next
session introducing
AI Hub, the one-stop
catalog for everything AI.
Thank you.
BANU NAGASUNDARAM: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]